[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Please
help me welcome
to the stage Jon Rudnitsky,
Hallie Meyers-Shyer, and Reese
Witherspoon.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
JON RUDNITSKY: Hi.
Thank you, thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Have a seat,
any seat you'd like.
Welcome.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Any seat, OK.
SPEAKER 1: Any seat
except for mine.
So reviews came
out this morning.
I don't know if
you've read them,
or if you guys don't read them.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
I don't read reviews.
SPEAKER 1: No?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: No.
SPEAKER 1: What is that
noise-making device?
REESE WITHERSPOON: That
means the reviews were great.
SPEAKER 1: Yay, applause.
I actually want
to read one, which
I guess will lead into the whole
talking about the story here.
"The unquestionable
feel-good movie of 2017."
Have you heard that?
Pete Hammond,
"Deadline Hollywood."
Congratulations on writing
an incredible story.
Hallie, this is your writing
debut, yes, directing debut,
and film debut in general?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Yeah, it's my debut.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So I guess, where
did the idea come from?
Where did this originate?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
It came from a bunch
of different places.
I had had the character of Alice
in my head for a long time,
of this woman who had sort
of made a lot of decisions
early in life, and then
started questioning them,
and that kind of
post-separation, post-divorce
time in a woman's life.
And I had a friend who had three
guys move into her family's
house growing up,
and I just thought
that was such an interesting
idea, and a great setting
for a comedy.
So I sort of put this
character in that scenario,
and it all came from there.
SPEAKER 1: So in real life,
was there the sexual tension
that ended up happening?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: I
actually don't know anything
about what actually happened.
It is a fictional film.
SPEAKER 1: Sure it is, right.
And Reese and Jon,
how did the two of you
get onboard the film yourselves?
REESE WITHERSPOON: I read the
script, and I just loved it.
I thought it was such an
original idea, and the idea
that a decision you make
at 25 isn't necessarily
the right decision for
the rest of your life.
And I think a lot of people are
at crossroads at certain times
and trying to figure out
chapter 2 of their life.
And so I met with Hallie,
and she was wildly impressive
and had a great vision for it.
And we went ahead.
SPEAKER 1: And Jon,
what about you?
JON RUDNITSKY: I mean, same.
I read the script
and was blown away.
It's also about three young
filmmakers who move out
to LA hoping to make it.
And me, Nat, and Pico can all
relate, obviously, to that.
So you know, I was honored
to be a part of it,
getting to work with these two.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Jon came
in on our first day of casting,
which is very special.
SPEAKER 1: Really?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And so none of you
knew each other beforehand?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: No, no.
Not really.
JON RUDNITSKY: I'd heard of you.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
We knew who Reese was.
JON RUDNITSKY: I'd
heard of you, yeah.
I had seen you in something.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
What'd you think of me?
SPEAKER 1: Right, so Reese,
you've been acting since,
what, you were 14, 15?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Yeah, 14.
SPEAKER 1: And so with hits--
gosh, "Pleasantville" still
one of my all-time favorites
from when I was younger,
"Cruel Intentions," "American
Psycho," "Legally Blonde,"
"Sweet Home Alabama."
[CHEERING]
This is the "Legally
Blonde" section over here.
"Sweet Home Alabama," "Walk
the Line," with which you won
the Academy Award.
Again, congratulations.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: So I guess you've
been putting out a movie
a year since you
were a teenager.
REESE WITHERSPOON: I guess so.
SPEAKER 1: You
were a child star,
and then went to
be an adult star.
How did you navigate
that complexity
without sort of going a little
bit typically child-star crazy?
REESE WITHERSPOON: I
mean, I don't know.
I wasn't really
a big child star.
I worked in movies,
and my parents
were very adamant that
I stay in high school
and that I went to college.
So I didn't really start working
with any kind of regularity
until I was about 19.
I got a big audition
when I was at Stanford,
and then I had to drop
out to do the movie.
And then I got another movie,
and I got another movie.
And so it just
started working out.
But I thought I was
going to be a doctor.
I'm not the kind of person
who would move to LA
and live in a car.
SPEAKER 1: Your parents
are doctors, right?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Yeah, my
parents are both doctors.
Yep.
SPEAKER 1: So did they
want you to be doctors?
Because my parents
were always like,
you can act with a
computer science degree.
You can't do computer science
with an acting degree.
Which was the only advice
I really ever listened to,
which landed me here.
So thank you, Mom and Dad.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
That's pretty good.
Yeah, they wanted
me to be a doctor.
SPEAKER 1: Really?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Yeah.
I'm pretty sure they still
want me to be a doctor.
SPEAKER 1: Do they call you
after they see your movies,
and like, Reese, we
really wish that you
had become a brain surgeon.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Less after the movies,
more after I do a talk show
and I talk about them a lot.
They're like, really
wish you wouldn't
talk about us all that much.
But they're good sports.
SPEAKER 1: You grew up
in the South, right?
REESE WITHERSPOON: I grew up
in Nashville, Tennessee, yeah.
And my dad was in the military,
so we were all over the place.
SPEAKER 1: How'd you
kick the Southern accent?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Oh, well, I
got advice when I was about 18.
I went into a casting
office, and they said,
you're never going to get work
with that terrible accent.
So I watched a lot of
TV shows, like "90210."
And I went to watch the way
that they would articulate,
and I would copy
them, like that.
So really it's Shannon Dougherty
I owe my entire career to.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
You got it down.
SPEAKER 1: Never would
have guessed that.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Tori
Spelling, Jennie Garth.
I'm just going to
leave it there.
SPEAKER 1: That's crazy.
JON RUDNITSKY: And Luke
Perry, and on and on.
SPEAKER 1: What's that?
JON RUDNITSKY: We're just
going through the entire cast
of "90210."
REESE WITHERSPOON:
The original cast.
SPEAKER 1: And Jon.
So dude, SNL.
People dream about
being on that show.
How did you make the crossover
from, I guess, sketch comedy TV
into this movie business?
JON RUDNITSKY: Well, I wouldn't
have gotten the opportunity
to even audition for this
had it not been for SNL.
That kind of helped put me in
a room with Hallie and Nancy
to begin with, which
was pretty crazy to even
have an opportunity to be
considered for this movie.
But my background is in acting.
I've been doing
theater my whole life,
and I studied theater at USC.
So I really have
always wanted to act.
I just happen to do comedy in
addition to that, you know?
SPEAKER 1: (MOCKING)
Happen to do comedy.
JON RUDNITSKY: I happen
to do comedy, you know?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: He's
not from the Midwest,
so we're not sure where
the accent comes from.
SPEAKER 1: It's like this
weird Michael Keaton accent.
JON RUDNITSKY: Is it?
Is it?
SPEAKER 1: Or Jack
Nicholson, yeah.
I happen to do comedy.
JON RUDNITSKY: I don't know
where it's coming from,
I don't know.
Do I do it all the time,
or is it just sometimes?
REESE WITHERSPOON: No, he
does lots of different voices.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Yeah, he's a comedian.
JON RUDNITSKY: Yeah,
there's just certain words
that I just like.
Like, I like to
say about "a-boat"
even though I'm from Jersey.
But it's more fun
to say "a-boat"
and I'm going to the "bahr."
Like, I'm going to the "bahr."
Why wouldn't you choose
to say it that way?
You could, just take what
you like from every accent,
I guess.
SPEAKER 1: Like "I pahked
the cah at Havahd Yahd."
JON RUDNITSKY: There you go.
SPEAKER 1: So Hallie now.
You turned 30 pretty
recently, yes?
I don't want to out
you here, your age.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
No, that's fine.
I'm good with it.
SPEAKER 1: I bring
this up because you
make me feel really
insignificant with my own life
decisions.
Being older than that
and having seen now
what you have
accomplished, I guess
it makes me feel like I've
had a few wrong choices when
I was 25.
But you started your
own acting career
when you were like, four, yeah?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Well, it's funny.
I'm being asked that
a lot, but I wasn't it
in no way a child actor.
My parents forced me to be
in their films basically.
But I'm very grateful,
because now it's
kind of like I have
this personal connection
and a little bit
of a photo album.
But no, I was always
on their sets,
so they'd throw me in the movie.
But it wasn't because I
wanted to be an actor.
SPEAKER 1: And who
are your parents?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Nancy Meyers,
the producer of our
movie, and my dad
is Charles Shyer, who was her
partner for a lot of my life.
SPEAKER 1: A long time.
And for those who don't
know, the two of them
have produced many things, such
as "The Intern," "The Holiday,"
"It's Complicated," "Parent
Trap," "Baby Boom," "Private
Benjamin," "Father
of the Bride."
If you've heard of any of those,
came from this family lineage.
And now the apple has not
fallen far from the tree.
This movie is
absolutely incredible,
and you're standing on your own.
So thank you for
continuing this.
And it is such a fun movie.
Was it as fun to write as--
I guess the question is,
was it as fun to write
as it was for us to watch?
JON RUDNITSKY: Oh, boy.
Got a little over-excited.
SPEAKER 1: That is
a literal mic drop.
JON RUDNITSKY: Come on, Google.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: It was
very fun to make the movie.
I love writing.
It's where I identify most
in the filmmaking process,
is with writing.
I mean, in my case, I don't
have a writing partner.
So you're completely alone
with these characters,
and there's so much
fun to be had there.
But it's really
challenging writing a movie
and layering your characters.
And
I think I did probably upwards
of 30 drafts of this script.
I did 15 on my own, then
I gave it to my mom.
Then another 15
came out of that.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Is that
scary, giving it to your mom?
I'd be like,
[SHUDDERS]
SPEAKER 1: Just hands it
back with a big, red X on it.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
No, because she's
the only person I give it to.
I gave it to her, and she has
such thoughtful, good notes.
I think good notes is just
raising the right questions.
She never said, you should
do this, you should do that.
It would just say,
why did they break up?
Just raising those
questions that
make you go home and think for
so long, like, oh my god, why?
I don't know, and I
have to figure this out.
So I don't even
remember the question,
but yeah, writing is a lot
of work and super rewarding.
SPEAKER 1: Was it fun?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: It was fun.
I love to write.
There's this great
Joan Didion quote,
"I don't know what I'm thinking
until I write it down."
And I really identify with that.
Sometimes you just don't know
how you feel about something
until you just write it down.
SPEAKER 1: That's interesting.
As someone who writes because
I have to answer emails,
I appreciate someone who
does it for recreation.
You grew up in the
industry, you grew up
around very successful parents,
and being on sets all the time.
Obviously you have written
a maturity into this film
that I wouldn't have
expected from someone
I guess as young as you are,
from a certain perspective.
So where did that
maturity come from?
Where did your larger view on
relationships and life happen?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: You
know, I think for me I
was trying a little bit to
honor the medium of film,
which I respect so much.
Film is forever,
and I didn't want
to write about trivial issues.
So for me, the themes of
family and divorce and starting
over are important.
So that's kind of why I think
Alice's story and crossroads is
a little bit weightier and
realer then the issues of sort
of which guy.
The kind of like,
20-something story.
SPEAKER 1: And I
enjoy in this that it
doesn't take the normal
slapstick kind of silly turns
that romcoms--
romantic comedies--
do in most cases.
So it was a pleasant surprise.
And I think that's
why, of course,
today the reviews
are coming out,
and they're all very positive.
So you've done a good job there.
Regarding the
characters, I guess.
So we saw in the preview
there's lots of other people
in it, obviously.
It's not just the three
of these people here.
Or the two of them
and a director.
Michael Sheen is
Alice's husband.
Candice Bergen is Alice's mom.
We've got Lake Bell, who's
a wonderful addition.
How did all of these
wonderful people
come to get attached to this
first-time director's film?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Well, casting
is such an important
part of the process
because you're sort of handing
your character off to somebody
and letting them
make it their own.
So it's such an important thing,
and we thought really deeply
about this.
And it was a really
nice mix, I think,
of newcomers and
seasoned actors.
And I think that mix
added something fresh
to the equation.
It really felt like there
was different generations
in this movie.
And I have to say, we
sent it to these people.
And sometimes you think
you'll never hear back.
And a lot of them responded.
And my mom had worked with
Bell before, so we knew her.
But the rest of the actors in
this movie were just good old
fashioned sending in the script
and hoping they'll say yes.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
You have to realize
as an actor you don't
get a lot of scripts
where you get to play
a character anymore.
SPEAKER 1: Really?
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Yeah, it's pretty rare.
And to have a fully fleshed-out
character with a beginning,
and a middle, and an
end, or a real journey,
or real lines to say,
or humor is really
an anomaly these days.
I mean, you're
honestly just reacting
to a green screen going,
[GASP]
And then to the director you're
like, what am I staring at?
And he's like, I'm not sure,
we're going to put it in later.
But just give me six
different reactions to it.
So most actors are
starving to do something
really meaningful and deep.
SPEAKER 1: I guess
I didn't realize
that the bad guy
with the green screen
was never preconceived
beforehand.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Sometimes they are,
and sometimes they have no
idea what's coming next.
SPEAKER 1: So working
with the Three Stooges--
was there any parallel
there, by the way?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: No.
SPEAKER 1: Why three guys?
I'm sidetracking here.
Why three guys?
Why not one?
Why not two?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: I think
good things come in threes.
It just was always going to be
a trio for me, I don't know.
SPEAKER 1: Fair.
OK, so back to my
original thought.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
It was always three.
SPEAKER 1: So this
is a little bit of a.
Spoiler some of you
have seen the movie.
We screened it here last night.
So at the end, I was
pleasantly surprised
to find that at the
end of the story,
Alice doesn't choose
any of the men.
Which is great.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
They just gasped.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Oh no.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Imagine that.
SPEAKER 1: You don't
need a man to be happy?
And it's refreshing to
see a romantic comedy
where the female protagonist
finds happiness on her own.
Jon, I'd choose you.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Do you
know how many people come up
to me like, what about Jon?
What about the
guy, that Jon guy?
SPEAKER 1: I did think that
you were going to go for Jon.
That Alice would go for Jon.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: So many
people say that to me, too.
JON RUDNITSKY: Yeah,
I'm writing a sequel
where we end up together.
"Home Again, Again."
SPEAKER 1: "Still Home Again."
I guess is one of the
most powerful things
about this movie, is that I
feel every woman is portrayed
as a strong woman, even like the
smaller supporting characters.
None of them are typically
your frail, weak sort
of women that are
often portrayed.
Was this a conscious choice
when you were writing it?
And I guess for you,
Reese, was this something
you noticed in the script that
attracted you to the role?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Yeah, I
don't play a lot of weak women.
I don't really know
any weak women.
My mother used to always say,
if you want to be a woman,
you'd better be tough.
And that's the only
kind of women I know.
That's what Hallie writes.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
I wouldn't have--
I don't know.
I also don't know
any weak women.
It wouldn't have come
naturally to me to write that.
She's vulnerable,
that's for sure.
And she gains
strength by the end
of the film, and
self-confidence, and feeling
like she's going to
be OK by the end.
I wasn't consciously thinking,
this is a strong woman.
I just thought, this as a
woman, and women are strong.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I agree.
Very well written.
And so Erika--
Olde?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Yeah, Olde.
SPEAKER 1: Produced
this as well.
So she's only been producing
for just a few years, too.
She's a new producer.
And I was reading
up on her, too,
and she produces films
primarily made by women as well.
So how did you find her?
How did she become attached?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: After
I had written the script,
we gave it to our
agents, who wanted
to help us get the
financing for this movie.
And Erika was the
right person, I think,
because her whole company is
based around women's stories.
And I think she
has a particular--
she loves these kinds
of movies, and she
wanted to tell women's stories
and help female directors.
So it was a really nice pairing.
And she's a young woman
herself, and it was great.
SPEAKER 1: That's wonderful.
So Reese, a little
side question, I guess.
Over the last few
years, so you've
been getting into
producing yourself.
And you produced
"Big Little Lies,"
which now you have a bajillion
Emmy nominations for that,
which is wonderful.
What made you want to
get into producing?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Well,
about five years ago, I
read probably the
worst script I've ever
read in my entire life.
And the part for a woman was
just absolutely dreadful.
Opposite a guy.
And I called my
agent, and I said,
well, this is just
a piece of crap,
and I don't want to do this.
And she said, every actress
in Hollywood wants this part.
And I thought, we deserve
better than these parts.
And so I was like,
I can either start
complaining about it, which
isn't going to do any good,
or I can do something about it.
So I started buying books
and turning them into movies.
And my first two were
"Wild" and "Gone Girl."
And so I just started
from there, and creating
parts for other women as well.
And that's sort of been the
next chapter of my life.
SPEAKER 1: So do you enjoy
performing still more?
Or are you aiming more
towards the producer side
moving forward?
REESE WITHERSPOON: No,
I like being an actor.
I really love it.
It's my first love.
I get on set, and
I get all excited.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
She's so good at it.
REESE WITHERSPOON: I enjoy
it, but I love producing.
And I'm really a big
reader, so I read a ton.
And I kind of have
an eye for what
is actually going to remain,
and what's cinematic.
Because not every book is--
things can be
beautifully written,
but just it's not
going to happen.
And I think those
two things together
really help create a
successful producing career.
SPEAKER 1: You should
produce a movie
you star in where
you play a doctor,
and it would satisfy everything.
REESE WITHERSPOON: I
should, you're right.
SPEAKER 1: Be a brain surgeon.
"Thanks, Mom."
Going back, I guess,
to the casting,
you have two wonderful
children that you cast.
Lola Flanery and
Eden Grace Redfield.
Is it harder to cast
roles for children
or to cast roles for adults?
And specifically for these
two kids, how did you find it?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: It's
really hard to cast children
because their parents
rehearse it with them.
So it's hard sometimes-- when
I was watching the auditions,
it would be like they've had a
very specific way of saying it,
and a specific rhythm.
And you feel like you might
have to undo that a lot.
But these two kids,
you could just
feel that there was
something supernatural--
not supernatural, but
very natural about them.
SPEAKER 1: They
were sort of ghosty.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Well, the little one
caught my eye, honestly,
because she was Reese's twin.
And we were like, that's
just a little Reese.
And then she happened to have
this fantastic comedic timing
and be super unique.
And Lola, I really
wanted somebody
in that part that could play
the comedy of being anxious,
but you wouldn't actually
be super worried for her.
You just felt like
this was a stage
she was going to come out of.
And I think Lola has kind of
an inner happiness to her.
She's very sweet, and then
the sweetness comes through.
And I think they just
both were so natural.
They didn't feel child actory.
SPEAKER 1: And Jon, I
guess your character--
you and Lola have great
onscreen chemistry.
Were you like that
off the camera, too?
JON RUDNITSKY: Yeah,
we really hit it off.
We would sing Adele a lot.
We were tight.
We all got along.
It was one big family almost
instantaneously, I would say.
Because the guys
actually ended up
living together during
the making of the movie.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Yeah, they live together.
REESE WITHERSPOON: They
decided when they got cast,
they would all live together.
JON RUDNITSKY: You didn't think
that would be such a good idea.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
It was a bad idea.
JON RUDNITSKY: But it
turned out all right.
It did, it turned out OK.
SPEAKER 1: Are you
still speaking now?
JON RUDNITSKY: Well,
yeah, a little bit.
No, we are.
We're talking, we are, we are.
Well, Nat's busy working
around the globe.
SPEAKER 1: Still
owes you some rent.
JON RUDNITSKY: But
no, we all talk.
We all love each
other a great deal.
SPEAKER 1: You
touched on family.
I guess the whole cast does
to me seem like a family,
like we're watching
this family literally
and figuratively on screen.
When was the first time that
everybody sat down together,
that everybody met?
Was there one point when
everybody got together?
REESE WITHERSPOON:
The rehearsals
and costume fittings.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Yeah.
There's a lot of intertwined
relationships in this movie,
so we did a lot of rehearsals
with the different--
like Jon and Lola, and then
Jon and Reese, and then
Reese and Nat.
It's like everyone has
a different relationship
in this movie, so we all
got together and talked
about those different dynamics.
I think that's when it
first started jelling.
SPEAKER 1: When did
you realize that you
had something
really special that
was kind of bubbling up here?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
That's a great question.
I think there was a really
great energy on the set.
It felt like we were
making a feel-good,
I thought, when we
were making the movie.
It had a nice energy.
My mom was the producer, which
added another family element.
It really, literally
was a family.
Reese's kids would come by, and
Jon's parents, and you know,
it was fun.
Why is that so funny?
JON RUDNITSKY: I had to work
on my lines with somebody.
The tone of the movie really
matched the tone on set,
honestly.
It really did.
SPEAKER 1: Oh,
that's incredible.
I would have loved to be a
fly in the room, I guess.
You don't do a table read
or anything for the movies,
do you?
For this?
REESE WITHERSPOON: I
think we did, didn't we?
Did we do a table read?
One of y'all came in-- somebody
who was auditioning it goes,
I read this with all my friends.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Oh, Nat.
Nat did a table read.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Nat did
his own reading in his house
with actor friends.
I was like, that's amazing.
Why didn't you invite any of us?
He was like, well, we all
just debated about this word
that none of us could say.
And we were like,
what was the word?
He was like, C-H-A-I-S-E.
I was like, oh, "shez."
And then Jon was like--
JON RUDNITSKY: "Schwooz."
REESE WITHERSPOON:
What do you call it?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: A "shayz."
SPEAKER 1: A "shayz."
A chaise lounge.
REESE WITHERSPOON: I
was like, it's a "shez."
And he's like, it's a--
JON RUDNITSKY: "Schwooz."
REESE WITHERSPOON: And
she's like, it's a--
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
It's a "shayz."
REESE WITHERSPOON: That was
one of the big debates on set.
So every time that
it was in the room,
they'd be like, there's the--
JON RUDNITSKY: The "schwooz."
REESE WITHERSPOON: The "shez."
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: It had
to be a chaise because you
sleep on it that night.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
That's why it's a "shez."
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: So you
couldn't sleep on a chair
that night.
REESE WITHERSPOON: You
know, in the South we call
it a sofa bed, a pullout couch.
SPEAKER 1: A sofa bed is--
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: A
sofa bed is different.
REESE WITHERSPOON: I don't know.
SPEAKER 1: It's
totally different.
Heard
REESE WITHERSPOON: I don't know.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: A
chaise is like a long chair.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Well, it's
definitely not a "shooz."
JON RUDNITSKY: A "schwooz."
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Jon is wrong.
That's the only thing I know
about the word "schwooz."
JON RUDNITSKY: But
you wish I was right.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, a chaise
doesn't have a pullout.
That's I guess that's
the difference.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
You're fancy.
SPEAKER 1: It's got the little
swoopy arm thing, doesn't it?
Maybe?
Am I wrong?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: It can.
It can have a swoopy arm.
JON RUDNITSKY: These are the
smartest minds in the world
right there.
What is it?
SPEAKER 1: And we
have random applause.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: We should
just google it, I guess.
SPEAKER 1: You can Bing it.
You'll get in
trouble here, though.
JON RUDNITSKY:
Nobody's Binging it.
Not a single person Bings it.
What Q&A are they
doing right now?
They're not.
Just the clown from
"It," and that's it.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Him and the balloon.
JON RUDNITSKY: Just
him and a balloon.
And a bunch of scared kids.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Any questions?
I kill me.
SPEAKER 1: I'm now picturing
somebody on a stage over there
with a balloon with a
little face drawn on it.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: So scary.
SPEAKER 1: OK, so the whole
movie takes place in LA.
Where did you
actually film this?
Was it actually in LA?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Yes,
it was actually in LA,
on the west side of LA.
And
SPEAKER 1: Whose house was that?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: A
lovely gentleman named Bill.
JON RUDNITSKY: It used to
be Cindy Crawford's house.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Yeah, it
kind of a Hollywood history
in that house.
JON RUDNITSKY: Jennifer
Garner's before that, right?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Yeah.
I found the house--
I googled "Spanish houses on
the west side of Los Angeles,"
because I knew that's where
we wanted to shoot the movie.
And I found it on a
real estate listing.
And we left a note
in their mailbox.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Is that crazy?
That stuff doesn't happen.
Ever.
It was really lucky.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Yeah, very lucky.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
It's crazy good luck.
SPEAKER 1: I guess talking
back to the family lineage,
everything your
parents did, too,
was set in these massive
just beautiful houses.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
They got to build theirs.
SPEAKER 1: Really?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Yeah, back in the heyday
of the romantic comedy.
They would build their sets.
So The nice thing about
building your sets
is when you write a scene, and
you say, she enters this way,
and he enters this way.
And then you can build that,
and it tells your story
through the set.
But what was amazing
about this house was
I had storyboarded
the whole movie.
And I was so nervous to find
a location because you write
things-- he fixes this
and this, and they
look through that window.
So I was like, I'm
going I have to find
a house full of windows.
It's kind of a visual
motif in the movie,
is people are looking
through windows
and seeing things happening.
And then I got to this
house, and the windows
were all in the right places.
I was like, this is it.
This window house.
SPEAKER 1: And it had
a guest house, too?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: And it had
a guest house, which was great.
SPEAKER 1: That's crazy.
And so was it empty?
Did you stage it?
Or was anything original--
this guy Bill, you said?
Does any of Bill's furniture
make it into the movie?
REESE WITHERSPOON: No.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
I don't think so.
We fully furnished it.
REESE WITHERSPOON: We
dressed the whole thing.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Some of
Jennifer Garner's curtains
are in the movie.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Thanks, Jen.
SPEAKER 1: Does
she get a credit?
Thanks to Jennifer Garner
for providing curtains?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: For
having good taste, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I guess so.
Bill wasn't living there.
What happens to the
person when you're
displacing them for-- how long
did it take to shoot this?
REESE WITHERSPOON: No,
he doesn't live there.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
He didn't live there.
REESE WITHERSPOON: He
was about to renovate it.
And I think we got to him right
before he was [INAUDIBLE]..
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Right before, yeah.
It was very lucky
that he didn't--
that's also an unusual thing.
Usually you have to
put that person up
when you inconvenience
them in such a way,
but he didn't
actually live there.
I don't know, something in the
stars were aligning for that.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
It was very special.
JON RUDNITSKY: Supernatural
is what it was.
SPEAKER 1: Because
It was the kids.
The kids brought it.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Like the kids.
JON RUDNITSKY: Like
the kids, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: How long
were you shooting?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
30 days, I think.
SPEAKER 1: You shot the
whole thing in a month?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER 1: Wow, that's crazy.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
How long do you
think it takes make a movie?
SPEAKER 1: I don't know, green
screens and stuff takes like,
eight months.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Actually, when we wrapped,
my mom was like,
I mean I usually--
I have five more
months after this.
It was amazing.
REESE WITHERSPOON: I think
a lot of movies are 30 days.
SPEAKER 1: What else?
REESE WITHERSPOON: 30, 35--
almost every movie
in my entire career.
Movies that don't have monsters
and blasters and aliens.
Superheroes.
You could actually just shoot
people writing and talking.
Yeah, it usually takes
about 30 to 40 days.
SPEAKER 1: With rehearsal
and everything, too?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Wow,
that's incredible.
I did not know that.
Learned something
new, thank you.
Audience, if you
guys have questions,
there's two mics in the aisles.
You can begin to line up here
and ask anybody anything,
whatever you would like to.
Oh, yes, we got one already.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Hi, guys, thanks for coming.
Before I ask my
question, Jon, I actually
saw your mom perform
stand-up comedy two weeks ago
at the Comic Strip.
JON RUDNITSKY: Wow, OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, she told a
story about how she messed up
your camp clothes.
JON RUDNITSKY: This is crazy.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
This all sounds amazing.
REESE WITHERSPOON: This
is great, is what this is.
JON RUDNITSKY: Do you want
me to comment on that?
Yeah, my mom--
first of all, my mom
is 57 and just started
doing stand-up.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Yeah.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
That's so great.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Go, Karen.
JON RUDNITSKY: Yeah,
that's pretty cool.
She's going to freak when she
finds out that you asked this.
And yeah, my mom tells
a story about when
I went to sleepaway camp.
My parents are divorced,
and my dad's very Type A,
and my mom's a total mess.
And my dad called her.
He was like, you put Jon's
name on all the clothes, right?
You labeled his name
on all the clothes?
My mom was like, oh yes,
of course, of course.
And she immediately hired
somebody to put the labels on.
But when they were all
done, it said my name
on the front of everything.
So it was like, down my zipper
and across my hat and stuff.
My mom's whole joke is when
I got back, I was crying.
And I said, I didn't
make any friends,
but everybody knew my name.
AUDIENCE: It got
a lot of laughs.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
That's amazing.
AUDIENCE: But my
question is for Reese.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
That was so funny.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
That was just her opener.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Yeah,
that was really funny.
JON RUDNITSKY: That's great.
You should do an open mic at
the Comic Strip with my mom.
AUDIENCE: So I'm also
a really big reader.
In fact, on Pacific
Standard's last movies
have been my favorite books
from the last five years.
So it's been really exciting.
But my question is,
so how do know--
I'm a very big believer
that the books are always
better than movies.
But it's been really
enjoyable to watch
all of my favorite books in
the last couple of years been
these amazing movies and shows.
So how do you know when
you're reading something
that this is going to translate
really well to the screen?
REESE WITHERSPOON: That's
a really good question.
It's a little complicated.
I think because knowing
what people will actually
buy and turn into a movie.
If it's two sisters during
the French Revolution,
it's just not going
to be a movie.
It's too expensive,
it's too niche.
So I think I try to
find things that are
universal, kind of relatable.
And my main directive has
just been have a woman
at the center of it
doing something--
sort of telling another aspect
of the female experience.
So "Gone Girl" is like, I
don't know, is she psychotic?
I don't know.
But it's something that took
an idea of the perfect girl
and kind of flipped
it on its head.
And "Wild," I loved the idea
of a woman versus nature.
Because you see men versus
nature all the time, right?
And then I never really
thought about what's
the movie where women are
up against the environment
by themselves.
So it's just stuff like that,
things that feel fresh and new.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So Reese, you talked about
the availability of roles
for men and women.
Over your 20 years
in the industry,
have you seen that
evolve, and do you
feel like we're
at a point in time
where there's a lot of
momentum for roles for women?
Or how does that work?
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Yeah, I mean, I
think it's a better
time than ever.
But I have to say,
when I started,
it was a good time
for women's movies.
Women were the stars
of their own movies
at the time I came up.
I was lucky I got
in a window where
I made "Legally Blonde"
and "Sweet Home Alabama,"
and I could be the
lead of a movie.
I think it's harder now,
particularly in movies.
You don't see women being the
star of movies very often.
I've heard people still
say straight to my face.
"We have one movie that has a
woman starring in it this year,
we don't need another one."
But the great news is with
all these streaming services
and the new platforms, now they
need content more than ever.
And that creates opportunity
for women of all ages, women
of all color.
So it's really kind of
broadening the spectrum
and creating more roles.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, back over here.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to thank
you guys for being here.
Hallie, you mentioned earlier
that you felt like you
were making a feel-good movie.
And I feel like we all
need that right now.
So thank you.
And then Reese, I just wanted
to say I was thinking yesterday
while I was watching
the movie, you're
one of my favorite actresses.
What would I say if
you were actually here,
and actually at Google.
And I was thinking
about how you've
had this history of
performing in "Election,"
in "Cruel Intentions."
All these women who are not
just strong but sort of strong
in ways that people
don't want them to be,
or don't quite understand,
and that they're
successful in ways that
don't fit with expectations.
And I think that's sort of
a really interesting message
for the women in Google
right now, many of whom
are in roles that people
don't expect them to be in,
or don't quite trust
them to be successful in.
And it's your particular
history of performance
is an interesting one right now.
And I'm not shocked to see this
many women here in this room
and screaming for "Legally
Blonde" and Tracy Flick,
although she was left
out of your recitation.
So I just wanted to
thank you for that.
And also, hi, Jon.
Your mom sounds cool.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Thank you.
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
JON RUDNITSKY: Sweet.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I feel like I have
so many questions
to ask Reese, because I
feel like we would be best
friends if we ever [INAUDIBLE].
REESE WITHERSPOON: I
think we probably would.
AUDIENCE: But you
actually said something
that changed my whole
question dynamic before.
You said there was a script
that you read that was
really crappy for the woman.
Did that ever get made?
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Yep, sure did.
Win an Oscar-winning
actress for the part.
AUDIENCE: Really?
Are you able to say what movie?
REESE WITHERSPOON: No, I'm not.
JON RUDNITSKY: Did it do well?
Or that got nominated
for Academy Award?
REESE WITHERSPOON:
No, it did not.
I was a terrible movie.
But you know, I've always
had a thing where--
back to your point
about being a woman who
does sort of unorthodox things.
I turned down so
many parts where--
I got a lot of opportunity
after "Legally Blonde"
to play the girlfriend
in superhero movies.
Girlfriend,
girlfriend-- I was like,
why would I be the girlfriend
when I could be the lead?
I would rather take less money
and be the lead of a movie,
show a girl that she can be
the center of her own story,
than be a very
wealthy girlfriend.
Because it doesn't
move the needle for me.
And I also had a little
girl when I was 23.
So it kind of shifted
my perspective
of what do I want
her to see on film.
I grew up with Holly Hunter, and
Debra Winger, and Diane Keaton,
and Meg Ryan.
And those were events for me
when they had movies coming out
on a Friday night.
That's what I wanted to see,
a woman who's figuring it out.
She doesn't know what
the next step of her life
is going to be.
And I just think that's
what drives me every day.
That's why I have a mission
just to create those parts
for myself, for other
women, for female directors
to have the opportunity to
tell women's perspectives.
Because if we don't see
women's perspectives--
I mean, we've talked about this.
Women in women's films
treat men differently.
The men treat the
women differently.
That's a narrative
that's important.
And I would say the same
thing about women of color,
women of different generations.
All different perspectives
need to be represented.
And it's just enough.
I've had enough of the same
people telling the same dang
stories.
If we don't see some
new perspectives,
society can't
change, and we can't
have different conversations.
And that's how I feel about it.
JON RUDNITSKY: Wow.
REESE WITHERSPOON: But I
don't really have an opinion.
JON RUDNITSKY: No,
no, no, not at all.
SPEAKER 1: And thank you to Jon.
JON RUDNITSKY: Also, hi, Jon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And my mom, whatever.
REESE WITHERSPOON: And Karen.
JON RUDNITSKY: And
Karen, of course.
SPEAKER 1: Back over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
My name is Brooke
Taylor, which is actually
a character in "Legally Blonde."
Which made me super popular
in fifth grade, so thank you.
And a question I got to asked
on my first day at Google
is if I could have lunch
with anyone dead or alive,
who would it be?
And I said Elle Woods.
And that made me even more
popular, so thank you.
Thank you very much for
the "Glamour" article.
I'm sure that's been
circulating quite a bit.
You have a lot of
ambitious women
in the room who are strong not
because they're strong women,
but because we're women,
and that's what women are.
Can you speak a little
bit to the article,
and just give us some
advice, and even talk
about how it's been
received if you've
gotten any sort of feedback?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Well, thank
you so much for saying that.
I worked really hard
on that article.
I probably did 30
drafts, because I
think it's really
important what you say.
Probably like,
three years ago, I
was asked to give a speech
at this "Glamour" event
about ambition and women,
and why that's considered
a negative trait in women.
And they did this
study at Columbia
that identified it as a
negative trait in a coworker,
as a female coworker,
that she's seen
as selfish or self-serving.
And I thought, why has
become such a negative thing?
I was always ambitious,
even as a little girl.
I didn't know you were
supposed to hide it.
So there's a new
Harvard study that women
who are seen as a vicious
hide it if they're single.
That just drove me up a
wall, because I thought,
run away from anybody
who doesn't like
your ambition, particularly
a guy or a partner.
Because it should be encouraged.
And it's not the
self-serving thing.
It's like most women who are
ambitious have a bigger goal.
We're community leaders,
we're strong family leaders,
we can change a lot and
create a lot of change.
But we're stymied
because of this stigma
around being ambitious.
I think it's why a
lot of women don't
run for office, because
we look at women
and go, of course
she wants to win.
Why shouldn't she win?
She's probably going to help us.
And I think we
have to change it.
We have to start
talking about it.
And I've had a lot of response
from men at big companies
who wrote me and said, I never
thought about it that way.
And I've heard women talked
about in boardrooms and stuff
as, boy, she's climbing.
And he goes, I'm going to
change the conversation.
You're talking about
your daughters.
You're talking
about your sisters.
We need women.
We're 50% of the population.
We're 50% of the change.
AUDIENCE: Amen, sister.
REESE WITHERSPOON: But I
don't have any opinions.
AUDIENCE: Over here.
SPEAKER 1: My question
is also for Reese.
It's about "Big Little Lies."
I'm actually born and raised
in Monterey, California.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Oh my gosh.
AUDIENCE: I know, it's rare.
And I wanted to ask
you about the decision
to change the
setting of that book
to Monterey, because it feels
really important to the story.
So why Monterey?
Why that story in particular?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Oh,
that's a good question,
because it's set in
Sydney, Australia.
The writer set it there, and
we decided to Americanize it.
Because I wanted to be in it.
So there's that, and I do a
terrible Australian accent.
And then Monterey
because we wanted
it to be in a coastal
town that wasn't
Los Angeles, because that
has its own identity.
The writer was--
David Kelley is from that
area, and lived in that area.
And the director,
Jean-Marc Vallee,
wanted to use
water as a metaphor
for the dark,
mysterious unknown that
lies inside of us, the secrets
that lie underneath the calm.
I don't know if you
all have seen it,
but the last episode
is you see why
he's always filming the ocean.
So yeah, it's a metaphor.
SPEAKER 1: Wonderful.
Yeah?
JON RUDNITSKY:
That's really cool.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys,
thank you for being here.
I'm Katie.
So my question is a little
interactive in nature.
Reese, it's directed
towards you,
but I would love it if you could
maybe use Jon as your student.
REESE WITHERSPOON: OK.
JON RUDNITSKY: Wow, all right.
AUDIENCE: So as I'm sure
you guys have heard,
as well as a lot of us in
this room have experienced,
dating in New York is
notoriously pretty tough.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Oh, gosh.
AUDIENCE: A girl or a guy
could use all the help
that we could get.
So I was wondering
if you would be
able to give us all a
refresher on the bend
and snap from "Legally Blonde."
Maybe using Jon as your student.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
OK, you want me
to teach Jon the bend and snap?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Well, first, you
have to know why
you're doing it.
JON RUDNITSKY: Sure.
REESE WITHERSPOON: You're trying
to get someone's attention.
JON RUDNITSKY:
Right, motivation.
REESE WITHERSPOON: OK, right.
So you pretend that you dropped
something on the ground.
JON RUDNITSKY: Uh-oh.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Uh-oh, there it is.
And so then you lean
forward like this.
And then you snap.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Good job, Jon.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Well done.
JON RUDNITSKY: The paws.
REESE WITHERSPOON: The paws.
JON RUDNITSKY: Oh my god.
AUDIENCE: I don't know how
I follow that question.
We've talked a lot
about the importance
of having really powerful,
strong female characters
represented in the
narratives we tell on screen.
But there's so much
work that goes in--
whether that's on the part
of producers, or writers,
or cameramen-- on the
back side of things
to make those characters
appear onscreen.
What advice do you have for--
there are lots of
creatives that are
at Google who, outside of our
9:00 to 5:00, are like myself,
or screenwriters, or work on the
production side or the editing
side.
What advice do you
have for trying
to get your material in front
of the right eyes in an industry
where there are so many barriers
to entry, especially for women?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Do
you want to take that?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Well,
I mean, in my opinion,
the best way to get
your content out
there is A, to have a
very original voice,
and to not be afraid to
tell your specific story.
Because then it feels very you.
And I think, like
Reese mentioned,
it's a really good time to be
a content creator, I think,
because there's
so many platforms.
So I think just not being
afraid to cold email people,
send your material out there.
I mean, I know it's
idealistic, but I
am a big believer
in good material
gets found and gets
recognized, you know?
And like Reese
mentioned, there's
not a lot of strong
roles for women.
And so if you are,
I hope, writing
those kinds of characters, I
think it will be recognized.
And from YouTube, to
Amazon, to Netflix,
I think all of these places
have their own content now.
I don't know if
we're-- or Google.
Wherever you want to
send your material to.
SPEAKER 1: YouTube Red.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Yeah, YouTube, yeah.
So I mean, that
would be my advice.
REESE WITHERSPOON: And
just start making stuff.
Don't get stuck.
Even if you make a
short with your friends,
or you get everybody
together on a weekend
and make a short film,
you're getting actual film
and experience under your
belt. And there are so many--
New York Film Festival has a new
program for female directors.
Warner Brothers is
doing a pilot program
for female screenwriters that
want to be directors that--
you write a 10-minute
short and submit it.
There's a lot of
those kinds of things.
And yeah, you just start making.
But don't get stuck.
I don't know, I just see a lot
of creative people get stuck.
And it's good sometimes
to work in a group,
too, because it pushes
you out the door.
You have a partner.
JON RUDNITSKY: Yeah, yeah, and
when I was first starting out,
YouTube was how I--
I mean, that's how
I got my agent,
was from making
sketches with buddies.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
That's great.
And I think it is--
I mean, even though
the statistics
are terrible about
being a female director,
I do think, because of
people like Lena Dunham,
people think that young women
might be great at what they do.
And I think she's paved the
way for a lot of young women
for people to recognize.
I do think it is, in
some ways, a good time
to be a female content creator.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
I looked down and looked up,
and there's 5 million people
asking questions again.
Yeah, Molly, hey.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Molly.
Super excited that
you're here, all of you.
Thank you.
So my question is for
Reese, I think you can--
Hallie and Jon, you
can both answer it.
Reese, you've done so
many different movies,
different genres, production
company, Draper James.
What's next?
What is one thing
you'd love to do?
And Jon and Hallie,
what's next for you?
What's your next big
project, something
you would like to
do outside the box?
REESE WITHERSPOON: Well, I just
extended my production company
into digital and
mobile programming.
So I'm going to be capable of
making more short-form content,
because I do think that's
the first step to finding
new female voices.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
That's great.
I mean, I don't know if I'm
doing anything outside the box.
But I'm definitely going to keep
trying to do what I did here
and make comedies,
which seem to be
fewer and further between now.
And put women at the
forefront of them.
So yeah, more of the same.
Jon?
JON RUDNITSKY: I'm working
on the show with my writing
partner for Comedy
Central at the moment.
And then I'd like to do more
good movies, keep working.
It'd be nice.
This is my first, really.
Our first.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: We have time
for a few more questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you all for being here.
So today there is an article
in the "New York Times"
about Rotten Tomatoes.
Basically, there's a bunch
of people in Hollywood
who are putting blame on
Rotten Tomatoes for movies
not doing well.
Basically saying when
these reviews come out
and they get an
aggregated score,
that kind of predicts movies not
doing well at the box office.
If the critics are
saying it's bad
and it's surfaced on
different sites like Fandango,
or even when you search
a movie on Google,
which is relevant
to all of us here.
So I'm curious what you think
about that, if that really
is something that's
relevant, if that's
something we can lay blame for.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: I
don't know about blame.
I mean, I think Rotten Tomatoes
is owned by Fandango, I think.
So it's one and the same.
You know, for me, I think
it's a part of the equation.
But I don't think the actual
audience cares that much
about it.
And I think Rotten
Tomatoes is largely men.
So we made a movie
about a woman,
and so I don't know that
they are necessarily--
I don't know.
For me, I wouldn't look at it.
I wouldn't judge a film by it.
But I am aware that it
is a big part of things.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think more men look
at the scores, too.
Like, my boyfriend
would say, [INAUDIBLE]..
And I'd be like, who cares?
REESE WITHERSPOON:
They've gamified art.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Yeah.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
I think it does
have an effect in
certain capacities.
If there's something
people really want to see,
they're going to see it.
But I think it can drive a
movie that might be on a bubble
to people waiting till later.
And certain movies like this,
we're coming on the box office.
We need people to show
up and see the movie.
And if you want more movies
with women at the center,
you have to show up
and buy the tickets.
It's hard.
It's data that the
studios look at.
And they think, oh, well,
that one didn't do good,
and this one didn't.
So they don't make more of
them It's just a numbers game.
But I will say we need--
Ann Patchett wrote
this amazing essay
about like, don't let other
people make your judgments
for you, you know?
Have your own opinions about
art, and books, and music.
I hate-- I have a 14-year-old
son, and he's be like, well,
I heard it's not good.
And I'm like, yeah, but
who did you hear it from?
And maybe you guys don't
have the same taste,
and maybe you're not
interested in the same things.
So I really encourage people out
there, form your own opinions,
have something to talk about.
See movies.
I loved seeing movies and
having a different opinion
than other people, because
that's what makes you you.
And we've taken that
out a little bit
by reading too many reviews, or
listening to too many people's
opinions on Twitter and stuff.
I think.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Probably two more questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Chloe.
So all this talk about
this quote-unquote
"strong female character"
got me thinking.
This is a question
mostly for Reese,
but I would love to hear
Hallie's thoughts too,
if you have any.
Obviously I love
"Legally Blonde,"
but one of my favorite movies
of yours actually is "Freeway."
I was thinking about
the how a lot of people
see women in action movies,
and how just a woman punching
someone or shooting someone
can be just enough for people
to give them the strong
female character label.
But obviously
there's like-- you've
been doing so many
romcoms, and comedies,
and "Big Little Lies."
And I was wondering
what you think
of the difference in value of
a strong woman in a comedy,
versus like a family drama,
versus an action movie,
like "Freeway," or
some more recent ones,
like "Mad Max" and
"Atomic Blonde."
REESE WITHERSPOON: All of
those genres are great.
And I think more
that like looking
for strong or weak, and
look, I answer that question,
because I think of myself
as a strong person.
But I'm just looking for
complexity, because women just
aren't good or bad.
There's this whole rainbow
of other things in between,
you know?
They're complex, and confused,
and contemplating things.
And some of them are just
plain strange, I don't know.
I want to see every
color of the rainbow.
I don't want to just see--
I don't know, sometimes I think
you just get watered down.
It gets watered down because
they don't understand
the complexity of
the female brain,
because you're not
a woman writing it.
Yeah.
What do you think?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
I don't know.
I mean, I don't see a
ton of action movies.
It's just not, as an audience
member, my favorite genre.
But I do think sometimes
the women in those movies
are considered strong because
they're acting like men.
And for me, the characters
that have meant most to me,
the ones that Reese
has portrayed,
are strong because they're
complex, and they're real.
There's something
real about them.
I don't think you see a woman
in an action movie and think,
that's me.
I'm just like her
in "Atomic Blonde."
Even though it can be super
entertaining and great
to watch, for me,
it's the relatability
of a character that--
if you see Reese on
screen being strong,
and she's going
through separation,
that might give you--
I can do it, too.
And I think that's, for me,
where the strength comes
from on screen.
SPEAKER 1: Jon, do you
have a favorite genre?
JON RUDNITSKY: Favorite genre?
SPEAKER 1: Movie genre?
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: You know
the right answer to that,
right?
JON RUDNITSKY: Not really.
I'm not really into
superhero action movies.
I do like smaller stories,
typically, but drama or comedy.
I just finished "Ozark."
I thought that was real good.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Oh,
that's really good.
JON RUDNITSKY:
Really good, yeah.
Something like that's--
SPEAKER 1: Cool with you?
JON RUDNITSKY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So we have time for
one more question here.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So first of all, thank you.
"Cruel Intentions,"
favorite movie of all time.
So that's part of
working at Google
is our colleagues
are incredible,
and half of my meetings I'm
just in awe at how talented
the people are in the room.
So I was curious about who you
guys have worked with where
you've had that moment of
like, oh my god, this person is
so impressive.
Who's the most impressive
actor that you've worked with?
Outside of Jon, obviously.
REESE WITHERSPOON: I
mean, Jon Rudnitsky.
JON RUDNITSKY: Thank you.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Gosh,
I've worked with some really
amazing, talented people.
But isn't a great that
you can be around people,
and you're like, wow.
And the great thing
about movies is
it's a collaborative experience.
This movie was amazing.
We had so much fun, and I loved
working with all these people.
I'm trying to
think of one person
that I was like, oh my god,
this person is so incredible.
AUDIENCE: Or maybe
super intimidated
when you found out they were--
you're like, I got this, but--
REESE WITHERSPOON: Oh, I got to
work with Jack Nicholson once,
and I could barely speak.
And it got to his close-up,
and he was standing there.
And I just kept inching into it.
So he goes, hey, kid,
get out of my close-up.
Because I'm a leaner.
I tend to lean on people I like.
He's like, get away from me.
But I was pretty
starstruck about that.
That was pretty cool, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: That's funny.
Jon, I guess on SNL,
too, you've had a lot
of people coming through it.
Have you experienced
anything similar?
JON RUDNITSKY: Well, I mean,
obviously on this movie,
getting to work with
these ladies and Nancy.
At SNL, specifically Larry
David is my comedy hero.
So getting to work with
him was pretty awesome.
SPEAKER 1: See the movie.
It comes out in theaters
tomorrow, September 8.
[APPLAUSE]
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER:
Such excellent questions.
REESE WITHERSPOON: Yeah,
can I say thank you?
You guys have been great.
That was so fun.
This was awesome.
SPEAKER 1: Help me
thank them for coming.
Thank you.
JON RUDNITSKY: So funny.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
That was awesome.